[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas esta mujer que
veis en pantalla es maría sanz la
presidenta pro europea de moldavia uno
de los países que con más diferencia
está viviendo la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania con más tensión no no estamos
exagerando la propia presidenta describe
la situación actual como el momento más
peligroso de toda la historia del país y
de hecho tan solo una semana después de
que rusia invadiera ucrania moldavia
solicitó sorpresa a unirse a la unión
europea un proceso que por supuesto no
será fácil ni tampoco rápido hablamos de
un país que rivaliza con la propia
ucrania por el título de país más pobre
de toda europa y que además tiene serios
problemas políticos empezando por que de
facto ni siquiera tiene el control
territorial y fronterizo sobre el
conjunto del país somos el vecino más
frágil de ucrania somos el país más
afectado por ella y somos el país que
tienen menos recursos para hacer frente
a la situación y las consecuencias de la
guerra ni cupo pérez como ministro de
asuntos exteriores de moldavia ahora
bien por qué tanta ansiedad de repente
quién monjos tiene que ver la invasión
rusa de ucrania con moldavia porque su
presidenta dice que este es uno de los
momentos más peligrosos de toda su
historia aquí es exactamente lo que
explica titulares como éste
24 de abril de 2022 de los funcionarios
estadounidenses ucranianos sopesan la
alta posibilidad de que putin invada
moldavia espera un momento podría llegar
a repetirse montaría lo que estamos
viendo en ucrania puede ser esta la
continuación de la guerra pues veamos
una división alimentada por rusia
[Música]
fue la vida fue la segunda república más
pequeña de la unión soviética y cuando
ésta se vino abajo y moldavia declaró su
independencia rusia respaldó una
rebelión separatista en transnistria
dando lugar a una especie de nueva
república
[Música]
de la misma forma que el río dniéper
divide a ucrania en dos el cni esther
divide a moldavia en dos regiones
claramente diferenciadas desde el punto
de vista étnico y lingüístico mientras
que al oeste del 'míster' moldavia está
formado por ciudadanos tenía montaba
rumano parlantes en transnistria domina
una clara mayoría eslava que habla ruso
ucraniano como lengua principal
el caso es que desde que se consumara la
ruptura entre estos dos territorios
tropas rusas unos 2500 efectivos
aproximadamente permanecen desplegados
en la república moldava pri nuestro
viana más conocida popularmente como
transnistria uno de los países no
reconocidos más extravagantes de todo el
planeta con unos 500 mil habitantes
aunque se cree que en realidad apenas
vive en poco más de doscientas mil
personas y esta estrecha franja de
tierra situada entre moldavia y ucrania
está dirigida por separatistas pro rusos
y vive en buena medida de rusia pues
cumple suministrar no sólo seguridad
sino también gas natural gratuito y
complementos para las pensiones
[Música]
digamos que en cierta forma a pasear por
las calles de tiráspol la capital de
transnistria supone algo así como
retroceder cuarenta años atrás en el
tiempo para regresar a una especie de
unión soviética con tintes modernizados
hablamos de un lugar donde sus
residentes viven bajo un aluvión de
propaganda rusa más allá de la hoz y el
martillo que aún mantienen su bandera
podemos encontrar muchas pero que muchas
diferencias con la extinta unión
soviética por ejemplo desde la década de
1990 la economía de transnistria ha sido
monopolizada por una empresa el sheriff
una compañía que fue cofundada por el ex
agente de la caja victor buscan con
ayuda de varios colaboradores suyos y
quien posee de todo y cuando digo de
todo es absolutamente de todo desde la
cadena nacional de supermercados hasta
el club de fútbol anónimo de la liga de
campeones- pasando por los gimnasios las
empresas de telecomunicaciones las
gasolineras el tabaco el alcohol bueno
es que incluso controlar el propio
partido gobernante de transnistria
conocido como renovación que tiene 29 de
los 33 escaños del consejo supremo
es decir transnistria no es un país
comunista sino más bien un país al
servicio de una camarilla de oligarcas
que lo controlan absolutamente todo y
por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar pues no existen muchas
oportunidades para aquellas personas que
no tengan lazos con esta pequeña élite
pero no nos desviemos el caso es que
ahora la guerra de ucrania está
volviendo a tensar y mucho la situación
tras la solicitud de adhesión de
moldavia en la unión europea que se
formalizó el pasado 3 de marzo del 2022
transnistria ha vuelto a exigir el
reconocimiento de su plena independencia
y eso eso no es todo
[Música]
luego el pasado 22 de abril un general
ruso rustam afirmó que el objetivo de
moscú pasaba por ocupar toda la costa de
ucrania ya abrir una ruta directa con
transnistria porque según denunció en
moldavia se oprime a los ruso parlantes
prácticamente en la misma acusación que
durante mucho tiempo el kremlin hizo
contra ucrania
lo que por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar ha hecho que a muchos en ticino
se le pongan los pelos de punta para
colmo apenas tres días después de esta
desafiante declaración una explosión
daño en tiráspol el ministerio de
seguridad del estado y un día después
dos explosiones más destruyeron antenas
utilizadas para retransmitir la radio
rusa y sabéis que nadie absolutamente
nadie reclamó la responsabilidad sobre
estos atentados lo que por supuesto ha
puesto solamente algunas preguntas
fueron acaso saboteadores ucranianos
intentando dañar a objetivos rusos o
fueron en cambio los propios rusos para
justificar algún tipo de operación
militar mediante lo que se conoce como
operaciones de bandera falsa
queridos amigos amigas moldavia es uno
de los países más pobres de toda europa
apenas tiene un diminuto ejército
obsoleto y mal equipado que ni siquiera
cuenta con aviones de combate y que
apenas tiene seis helicópteros de
transporte sus tanques o un poco más que
antiguallas que encajaría mejor en un
museo que en un campo de batalla y
además el país apenas cuenta con seis
mil soldados además moldavia nunca ha
perseguido incorporarse a la otra y de
hecho desde 1994 el concepto de
neutralidad está recogido en su propia
constitución así que la pregunta es qué
demonios podría estar buscando ruso en
un país que no puede suponer ninguna
amenaza existe realmente el riesgo de
que escale el conflicto pues bien
encrucijada
[Música]
exactamente con qué objetivo o moscú
podría querer extender el conflicto a
este nuevo país o amigos o sea tiene una
amplia historia a la hora de recurrir a
este tipo de operaciones de bandera
falsa y el propio presidente del esquí
dijo alto y claro que las explosiones
eran obra de moscú y aún más según la
inteligencia militar ucraniana en
transnistria se habían preparado una
enorme cantidad de folletos instando a
los rusos a que se levanten en armas
contra moldavia o incluso también contra
la propia ucrania y de hecho al comenzar
la invasión rusa una de las primeras
cosas que hizo el ejército ucraniano fue
precisamente dañar los puentes que las
tropas rusas podrían llegar a utilizar
para apoyar un ataque sobre desa desde
la propia transnistria pensaba que a los
1.500 efectivos rusos hay que sumarles
los entre 4500 y 7.500 soldados que
componen el ejército y transnistria en
total entre 6.000 y 9.000 soldados que
moscú podría utilizar para alcanzar los
objetivos tanto en ucrania como en la
propia moldavia los soldados rusos más
el ejército de transnistria podrían
terminar en keys y no en una hora alexéi
tulbure analista político y embajador
moldavo ante las naciones unidas claro
que no se trata sólo de los rusos en el
municipio de covas nada un pueblo en el
norte de esta región separatista se
encuentra el depósito de municiones más
grande de toda europa del este
vamos a estar hablando de unas 20.000
toneladas de municiones de la edad
soviética que he llegado el caso de los
ucranianos podrían querer neutralizar o
incluso intentar apoderarse de ellas
para que os hagáis una idea de todo lo
que pueda haber allí metido en el año
2005 la academia de ciencias de moldavia
estimo que una explosión en este almacén
sería algo así como comparable a la
explosión de la bomba nuclear sobre
hiroshima en 1945 claro que estamos
hablando de material muy pero que muy
antiguo y que fue renovado por última
vez hace ya más de 30 años a saber cómo
están pero aún así la posibilidad está
sobre la mesa y esto es algo que podría
contribuir a escalar el conflicto en
cualquier caso evidentemente lo que más
aterra en chisinau es que el país pueda
terminar como la propia ucrania el
futuro de moldavia depende de si el
ejército ucraniano se mantiene luchar no
sólo por ucrania sino también por
nosotros
julian grossa analista del instituto de
políticas y reformas europeas de
valdavia haber por fortuna hoy una
invasión a gran escala de moldavia por
parte de rusia aparece algo
prácticamente inviable el desastre
militar al que se han enfrentado en
ucrania puede haber frenado por completo
esta posibilidad ahora bien quiere decir
esto que en moldavia no tiene de qué
preocuparse pues amigos amigas nada más
lejos de la realidad
en este caso moscú cuenta con otras
armas además la presidenta sandú llegó
al poder en 2020 con un mensaje
claramente crítico como es y muy pero
que muy pro europeo mientras que su
contrincante electoral y actual línea de
la oposición es todo lo contrario igor
dodon líder del partido socialista es un
político prorruso y marcadamente anti
occidental así pues estar al kremlin
pensando en una operación de cambio de
sillones como podría intentar conseguir
este objetivo haz que amenaza real se
enfrenta a moldavia vamos a responder de
forma concreta a estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver qué es
exactamente lo que podrían querer
conseguir los rusos en este pequeño y
pobre país del este de europa atentos
la unión europea'
el día 15 de noviembre del 2020 maya
sandú ganó las elecciones con una
aplastante mayoría para que os hagáis
una idea entre las vías proactivo ni más
ni menos que el 93 por ciento de los
apoyos esto supuso la salida del poder
de la facción pro rusa de la política
moldava fue toda una sorpresa para moscú
hasta ese momento su aliado y gordon
parecía contar con un enorme poder había
sometido a prácticamente todas las
instituciones del país y tenía mayoría
en el parlament o incluso se sospecha o
no se sospecha por ser suave y utilizó
esta enorme concentración de poder para
vigilar de forma ilegal a sus
contricantes políticos y por si fuera
poco también recibe un importante apoyo
financiero y político de moscú pero
sabéis que ni con esas
[Música]
las guerras internas entre las
diferentes facciones pro rusas y el
creciente descontento popular hicieron
que a finales del 2020 el viejo debate
moldavo entre mirar más a occidente o
mirar más a rusia se inclinará
finalmente por mirar a occidente e
intentar la integración de una vez por
todas en la unión europea eso sí con
todo la principal promesa de sando fue
la lucha contra la corrupción y los
oligarcas sin escrúpulos como un momento
o un mensaje pro europeo y
anticorrupción en contra los oligarcas
uff ese cóctel es demasiado para la
rusia de putin demasiado sea como sea
hablamos de una apuesta que se consolidó
en julio del 2021 cuando el partido
acción y solidaridad de malla sandú
obtuvo una clara mayoría absoluta en las
elecciones parlamentarias y es que
amigos hasta este momento mundo había
sido un auténtico desastre no sólo es
junto con ucrania el país más pobre de
toda europa con un pib per cápita de
apenas 4 mil 500 dólares para que os
hagáis una idea el equivalente a países
como paraguay guatemala o el salvador
sino que hace 30 años el país tenía casi
4 millones y medio de habitantes y hoy
en cambio se calcula que su población
podría ser incluso inferior a 23
millones es decir hablamos de un país
que no solo ha experimentado un enorme
desastre económico sino también un gran
éxodo de población de hecho las remesas
se han convertido prácticamente en la
primera industria del país suponen y el
16 por ciento de toda la economía
y no sé un buen ejemplo de cómo han
funcionado las cosas en este país no
tuvimos en el 2014 cuando saltó la
noticia de un escándalo bancario que
rápidamente pasó a ser conocido como el
robo del siglo en apenas tres días
aproximadamente mil mil millones de
dólares fueron robados de tres bancos
moldavos y lavados en el extranjero
hablamos del equivalente a una octava
parte de toda la economía nacional y lo
que quizás resulta más sorprendente de
todos la operación fue dirigida por el
oligarca más rico del país vladimir
plata con el apoyo del mismísimo
gobierno el caso es que por todos estos
motivos por los que mayas 'no ganó
finalmente las elecciones en 2020 y lo
hizo con un objetivo muy claro
modernizar y limpiar de corrupción a
moldavia para poner al país en dirección
a la unión europea algo que tal y como
os podéis imaginar no le hizo ni pizca
de gracia al kremlin y de hecho al poco
de estrenarse en el cargo la nueva
presidenta comenzaron los problemas como
es que la pregunta es qué puede hacer la
rusia de vladimir putin para recuperar
su influencia en moldavia pues atentos
de mano
la pregunta es podríamos intentar un
golpe de mano para forzar un cambio
político moldavia y ojo que esto es algo
que podrían conseguir por varias vías
primero una operación de bandera falsa
en transnistria podría darle la excusa a
moscú para desatar una campaña de
castigo militar y económico contra
moldavia rusia utilizará cualquier
influencia que tenga para garantizar que
moldavia tenga un gobierno perros o irán
por un cambio de régimen diplomático
extranjero a declaraciones a economías
podrían por ejemplo amenazar bueno no
sólo amenaza con atacar el país con
misiles o incluso detener finalmente
éxito en ucrania por difícil que hoy nos
pueda parecer intentar cambiar el
gobierno por la fuerza esta sería quizás
la posibilidad más drástica pero amigos
también podrían emplear estrategias de
guerra económica rusia podría desatar
toda una tormenta económica sobre
moldavia porque lo cierto es que rusia
tiene la economía moldava acogida de
pies y manos
y es que veréis por un lado el oso ruso
suministra casi todo el gas del que
dependemos para hacer funcionar su
modesta industria y abastecer la
calefacción del país y podéis creerme
eso digo que hablamos de un país donde
en invierno hace frío mucho frío y
exactamente algo parecido ocurre con el
petróleo además las principales tuberías
pasan por transnistria así que la
amenaza sería más que factible de hecho
esto es algo que moscú ya ha utilizado
para obtener ventajas políticas por
ejemplo en octubre del 2021 o moldavia
se vio obligada a declarar el estado de
emergencia después de que gazprom
redujera los suministros en un tercio y
exigirá que moldavia pagará más del
doble del precio anterior para mantener
el flujo de gas eso o que aceptara un
nuevo tipo de acuerdo gazpron ofrecía
moldavia un nuevo acuerdo de gas a
cambio de vínculos más débiles de la
unión europea grupo ruso acusado de
utilizar la crisis energética para
castigar al nuevo gobierno prooccidental
simon dhabi aceptaba modificar su
acuerdo de libre comercio con la unión
europea y retrasar la aplicación de las
normas comunitarias entonces y sólo
entonces tendrían gas barato y abundante
al final según parece se quedaron a
medio camino cuando había consiguió gas
y rusia- concesiones políticas pero eso
no es todo cerca del 80% de toda la
electricidad de moldavia es producida
por centrales situadas en la república
separatista de transnistria y la
compañía eléctrica de propiedad rusa ha
venido aumentando considerablemente los
precios y obligando a chisinau a
negociar la compra de electricidad por
periodos muy cortos de tiempo de esta
forma si un mes no se renueva el
contrato de electricidad o se interrumpe
el suministro de gas nadie va a que
paramos la vía podría ser más
considerable
[Música]
amigos hoy por hoy montado está
intentando superar esta situación
construyendo conexiones eléctricas con
rumanía pero éstas tardarán años en
estar listas los gobiernos productos no
hicieron nunca nada para reducir la
dependencia de moldavia de moscú pero
eso no es todo casi a la desesperada del
ministerio de infraestructuras y
desarrollo regional ha apuntado que el
país está barajando comprar la
electricidad a ucrania pero claro y
realista depender de un país en guerra
que está siendo sometido a fuertes
bombardeos no parece la mejor opción del
mundo la libertad y la independencia
energética tienen un coste para nosotros
y después del inicio de la guerra en
ucrania no tenemos más remedio que pagar
este costo de la independencia a andrey
espino un ministro de infraestructuras y
desarrollo de los labia por supuesto la
idea de moscú podría pasar por que todos
estos problemas terminen desgastando al
gobierno proeuropeo y lleven a los
moldavos a abrazar de nuevo a la madre
patria rusia y ojo porque una evaluación
de inteligencia publicada por estonia a
este mismo 2022 apuntó muy claro a que
el kremlin estaba ya trabajando
activamente para derrocar al actual
gobierno proeuropeo según apuntaba este
informe hemos que utilizaría como armas
precisamente la dependencia energética
la influencia de la iglesia ortodoxa con
la que putin se lleva particularmente
bien y la propia televisión en ruso
y sabéis que lo cierto es que la propia
presidenta tiene muy pocas dudas de que
el clima político va precisamente en esa
línea las fuerzas políticas rusas en
moldavia y han estado hablando de
protestas masivas ya han estado pidiendo
al gobierno que renuncie y celebra
elecciones parlamentarias anticipadas
para que puedan culpar de las
dificultades económicas y los altos
precios de la energía al gobierno maya
sandú presidente de moldavia amigos
amigas moldavia 3 a un tiempo muy
difícil a los incrementos del precio del
gas y de la electricidad se suma el
impacto de la guerra por ejemplo unos
100 mil refugiados ucranianos se han
asentado en el país una cantidad enorme
para un país tan pequeño y pobre además
cerca del 14 por ciento de las
exportaciones montadas que hubieran
alcanzado ucrania bielorrusia y rusia se
han detenido casi por completo y la
inflación se ha disparado hasta el 22
por ciento por el mayor coste energético
y también por el incremento del precio
de las importaciones porque se ha
interrumpido el tráfico a través del
puerto de esa que es el principal puerto
utilizado por el comercio mundial
recordad que hablamos de un país sin
salida al mar
[Música]
para colmo las remesas procedentes de
los países en conflicto también se están
desplomando pensadas que sólo rusia
supone más del 10 por ciento de todos
los ingresos que moldavia obtiene por
esta vía es decir que el kremlin podría
estar tentado a complicar aún más las
cosas con protestas en las calles en
transnistria cortes de luz y gas o
incluso la amenaza de utilizar acciones
militares ya sabéis supuestamente para
proteger a la población culturalmente
rusa quizás la mejor noticia hasta ahora
para moldavia haya sido precisamente lo
mal que las cosas le están yendo al
ejército ruso en ucrania pero llegado
hasta aquí y turno para ti crees que
finalmente putin intentará cambiar el
gobierno de moldavia será esta la vía
para escalar aún más el conflicto
dejamos por aquí abajo vuestros
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y suscribir los avisos
políticos si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]